what is the biggest challenge in  transitioning from your physics career  to your science educational efforts well  I guess the biggest challenge was giving  up my physics career I was about to  retire and I wanted to retire for  various reasons but most physicists go  on doing physics research particularly  theorists like me who don't need any  equipment to do it however I was  committing myself to a project that  would take a year and a half full-time  work to chair the committee that  developed the framework for k-12 science  education and it was a choice do I take  this one on or do I continue doing my  physics and I thought well I could write  a few more physics papers would be read  by a few people but if we really could  do something that improved science  education nationally that would be a  worthwhile effort so I decided to stop  doing physics and start doing education  work